hi in this video we are going to talk
about vitamin D the chemical name of
vitamin D is 125 dihydroxy
cholecalciferol otherwise it is known as
vitamin d3 which is the active form of
vitamin d notice that it has hydroxy
groups right it is d3 and that's why I
think has three hydroxy group and it's
structure is overall pretty much similar
to our cholesterol backbone right and it
also work like a steroid hormone now
most prominent role of vitamin D is to
maintain the cereal serum calcium and
phosphate levels so in this video we are
going to talk about all of those things
its source how it works what are the
diffusion syndromes and all of these
things
now vitamin D at a molecular level works
by other intracellular receptors the
receptor for vitamin D is bound by hsp90
in the cytoplasm when the vitamin D is
absent but in presence of vitamin D the
hsp90 block is removed and as a result
vitamin D receptor on the gunwale format
can move into the nucleus and once it is
in the nucleus it can star
transcriptional event now vitamin D
receptor along with the vitamin D bound
to it forms a receptor home dimer and
that binds to the vitamin d3 response
elements and that leads to mini level of
genetic changes and these mechanism is
pretty much similar to steroid hormones
like estrogen progesterone etc now let's
talk about its metabolism so we know
that cholesterol biosynthesis tecna's in
a sequential fashion and one step an
intermediate is known as 7d high draw
cholesterol is eventually converted to
cholesterol this 7d hydral cholesterol
can also be converted with the help of
sunlight to our active form of vitamin
d3 but this
process is more elaborate which we would
come in a moment so it turns out
sunlight has important effect to produce
the vitamin D orbital mean they can be
synthesized in a wood with the help of
sunlight how is that it turns out
freedom in d3 synthesis takes place in
this skin at least the beginning part
expressing the skin so there are many
formats of vitamin D which can be
obtained in food items for example in
case of vegetables vitamin d2 or our
vocal C Farrell is obtained and vitamin
d3 is obtained from many animal sources
such as fish dairy products etc now
let's talk about the vitamin D enriched
food which are like dairy product cheese
whole grain cereals butter egg whites
milk and fish all of these things are
very much enriched in vitamin D now
let's look at how vitamin D is
chemically synthesized in our body we
already talked about 7 D hydro
cholesterol which is the intermediate of
these cholesterol biosynthesis pathway
which can be channeled with the help of
sunlight into another intermediate known
as cholecalciferol now cholecalciferol
is a primitive version of the vitamin d
you can understand it like that the
political civil would immediately
channel to the liver where
cholecalciferol would be transformed
into Kelsey diode and this calcium is
actually two hydroxy group as the name
suggests guy all and it is otherwise
known as 25 hydroxy vitamin d3 because
and the enzyme that performs this
hydroxylation reaction is 25 hydroxy
lays then Kelsey died all or 25 hydroxy
vitamin d3 moves to kidneys and in the
kidneys Kelsey died all gets converted
into Kelsey trial on 125 dihydroxy
vitamin d3 this
the name of I mean the active format of
vitamin d3 or LC triode so this is how
vitamin d3 is synthesized in our body
now let's look at what is a major role
of vitamin d3 vitamin d3 allows calcium
reabsorption or increase the rate of
calcium reabsorption from the industry
apathy mía that means blood level of
calcium gets increased after vitamin d3
is actually not only that vitamin d3
ensures that another amount of calcium
is reabsorbed from the distal convoluted
tubules of the difference that means in
the kidneys it also play a major role
for reabsorbing calcium and increase the
blood calcium levels once the blood
calcium level is increased it can be
ready ready mately
available for depositing on to the bone
so bone marrow mineralization is an
important function of vitamin D as a
result when there is a deficiency of
vitamin d3 there is problems associated
with the bones known as duplicates which
is present in case of the babies and
osteomalacia in case of adults when the
bone density is altered mineralization
properties altered boon become more
porous and tender so this kind of
disease is known as osteomalacia not
only that it also increases the risk of
osteoporosis with the bone density is
very much reduced and wound becomes
sponge-like and fragile and it increases
the chance of fracture now along with
vitamin d3 parathormone which is
secreted from the parathyroid gland
plays vital role to maintain calcium
phosphate homeostasis so parathormone
calcitonin and vitamin d3 together work
like a chain and ensures calcium and
phosphate homeostasis is maintained in
the body definitely it helps in bone
growth and neural function because for
neurons calcium is also very much
important so let's look at how calcium
how vitamin d3 is absorbed after eating
a meal or eating food which is enriched
in calcium calcium and vitamin d3
vitamin d3 would be absorbed
in the in this time in the intestinal
epithelium they are as vitamin d3 is a
fat-soluble vitamin so it would be
absorbed along with the Fatimah series
so all the various in my series have the
vitamin d3 with it and it would be
absorbed in the intestine then it comes
to the blood and then it could be used
for other purposes
now causes a vitamin deficiency includes
improper absorption in the intestine or
in case of kidney disease LC diode could
not be converted to calcium that's a
problem and that's why active format of
vitamin d3 is not available in the blood
in case of liver disease cholecalciferol
cannot be converted into Kelsey dial
that's another problem and all these
things result in vitamin D deficiency
and improper calcium homeostasis which
might eventually increase the risk of
bone disease and risk of fracture so I
hope this video was helpful and last we
wanted to tell you that the key way by
which you can detect the vitamin D
deficiency is by measuring vitamin D
levels in the blood and I hope this
video was helpful if you liked this
video give it a big thumbs up don't
forget to Like share and subscribe thank
you